it's the second most commented on video
on his channel it's 136,000 comments
it's very tempting to when you do
something impactful to become complacent
and to think that that's it I can my
legs up now relax one of the most
effective people I've seen in dawa are
not Scholars and not students of
knowledge in fact some of the students
of knowledge and Scholars have been the
least effective in that I've seen
because they just don't have the
interpersonal skills one of the
strongest things that we have to our
disposal as a Muslim people is our
numbers we are the youngest demographic
in terms of religion according to Pure
research 2050 200000 we're going to be
the number one religion place if every
one of us did I mean not even all of us
if a big chunk of us just had one
direction that we were going in produce
content knowledge da and done all these
kind of things even if it's not every
single one of us even 30% for the sake
of argument or 40% or 10% it would
create significant demographic shifts KL
young obviously being one of the
psychoanalysts he said that the West are
technological Giants and moral midgets
we can say we respect the fact that the
western civilization has done this we
accept that they've done complishment
and at the same time we feel that our
morality is a superior morality all
sports are the same unless you're making
it as like you know a football soccer
player if you're a fantastic soccer
player then you have someone who can
fight pfor pound the guy who can fight
is probably better than you without it
you won't know how to defend yourself or
your family because you're not going to
be doing kick cups when someone punches
you in the
[Music]
face may Allah unti Nots from our
tongues expand for us our chest allow us
to speak the truth allow us to be alone
in this room without the influence ofan
may Allah forgive us for our slips and
mistakes and allow us to be leaders for
the
righteous welcome back to the realest
podcast in the the three Muslims right
now we're joined here with brother
Muhammed hijab abdah
Andi and
myself so what brings you guys to Canada
the
coffee we have a fantastic conference
here that has been hosted by the
esteemed she osta uh which has been
throughout Canada and um obviously the
theme has actually been um a response
almost to the what's been happening in
in Palestine and we wanted to get
energized the base in all parts of the
West so North America in Western Europe
and stuff like that so alhamdulillah
we've been able to do that it's very
successful and a great turnout and
people are very passionate about this
aldah may Allah keep you guys strong and
and just preserve you guys for all
you're doing I want to jump right into
the P Morgan debate that happened
recently so it's been known that we
should be very careful and cautious with
the platforms that we engage in because
they can cut things up take them out of
context and they they reclaim the
narrative that they want to report but
recently you did go on Piers Morgan so
how did your old view I guess evolved to
now did you have a talk with him did you
kind of set the ground rules before that
how did that go no it was what it was I
mean most of what happened is what you
saw there were a few things here and
there that happened before and after
which I not met it's not really
beneficial for me to mention it now the
point is is that alhamdulillah it had
the impact of changing the narrative and
one can see that from the comments and
the amount of it I think it's the second
most commented on um video on his
channel it's
136,000 comments not like not likes or
views and it's the as it stands almost
the third most watched you know video on
his channel the Bassam one done even
better in terms of um views it's almost
on 20 million um he's got a massive
popularity by the way in the Arab World
very well known black an aess celebrity
in in in Egypt and the Arab world so uh
those two are now the most viewed you
know things on Palestine on his channel
and so as such they've they've fulfilled
the objective of putting the Palestinian
cause forward and alhamdulillah I think
it was successful but we can't always uh
you know dwell too much on these things
we have to plow forward can't become
complacent because it's very tempting to
when when you do something with which is
impactful to become complacent and to
think that that's it I can I can put my
legs up now and put you know and relax
but this when you see the images that
we've been seeing right before this
podcast started and we were looking at
it and very very like it's been it's
really like made me to have grief to be
honest with you you know you see these
images you can't we cannot um you know
become complacent so there's there's
things to be done here 100% Abdullah did
you watch the interview yeah what did
you think when you first watched it
Abdullah was the one of the main people
I consulted right
before most of the points that I got
were from him that bathroom example was
directly from him he tell p Morgan that
what would you do if I threw you in the
bathroom I said that's a good one I'm
going to say that yeah someone broke
into your house and confined you the
bathroom would you being aggressive you
tried to break out your bathroom kick
him out yeah yeah like oh how dare you
break out your bathroom I left you in
the bathroom you should I'm so generous
you should be so pre appreciative of it
abdalah by the way is's one of the guys
I always consult when I have big
events because because of his his
experience in the field you know he I
always end up using something he tells
me like 80 to 90% of the time it's
amazing may Allah bless you guys amens
so so what was it like when you watched
it afterwards well look there there's
one thing making the arguments right but
um P Morgan who's got this very abrasive
and very insistent style uh mammed J was
a perfect antidote to that um he kind of
like CU pis Morgan tries to bully people
so what you need against bully is a
bigger
he's like I see you Bu you're bullied I
raise
you yeah so um and that was good because
P Morgan actually got uh was actually
got kind of effectively called out um
and you
know like considering that even though
pis Morgan it's his platform right and
he can cut the show when he wants he can
stop you know I want to raise this point
because not many people don't noticed
this so P Morgan showed a clip of
mhammed ja's giving um a talking head
video saying that p m would never invite
me on and give and and so on and so
forth right and so he goes all right
I've invited you on now what you have to
say and it's like and then mam pointed
out he invite me on finish the sentence
yeah to a fair platform right and that
remains to be seen and guess what mam
was proven right again right because Ben
Shapiro was given about 44 minutes and
it was mostly uninterrupted like just
just tell us you know just tell us what
you want to you know open your heart to
us Ben sh we're just going to listen
whereas for him he was constantly you
know challenged and it was for 22
minutes so he gave him half the time
that he gave and even with um basam YF
was about 33 minutes you understand so
it's not the same platform he was still
proven rights and so Subhan Allah so
yeah and of course there's a few other
things I I noticed that was uh you know
P Morgan just basically lying he said he
never said I think he about B yeah yeah
Bassam you mean I mean that that that
was different obviously uh interview but
uh but you know Bas youf said that you
mentioned 44 babies being be and you
know uh that's not not true and he goes
I never said four4 babies being so
someone put a clip of him Dr posting it
to what he said previously maybe the Ben
Shapiro um interview where he now he
said he said 44 babies were killed some
of whom he said like that so so he said
oh I say I didn't say all 44 were bed no
I said bring me the 44 babies being stop
Piers Morgan because you did say that
and you know and you did mention that
some of them at least some of them but
he tried to play these game anyway so
that's what he's like so alhamdulillah
it was it was quite satisfying uh to see
um mamad jab kind of taking down a peg
or two I think the audience noticed it I
looked at the comment section I couldn't
find a single
non-muslim right or even Muslim that uh
you know uh that would say anything
negative uh about muhamad J's
performance in fact they all were
criticizing P Morgan say oh you know
this is he's just hypocritical and it
was very important that he he could
condemn um civilians being Ked if it was
Hamas committing it but the greater
number of child
dead yeah he just like oh you know I
don't want to talk about I don't want to
you know defend itself I I can't like
and MOB kept pressing that you know him
upon on that and everyone noticed it
everyone noticed it there's there's also
point there some really good also funny
tactics like saying why are you
stuttering you know I'm not I'm not sure
like I don't think he was stuttering in
a sense of like the but he paused in his
speech and that was great tactic to use
because it highlighted to the viewer if
you're not if you weren't conscious of
it that he yeah he was stumbling over
his words he didn't actually know what
to say because he was being hypocritical
so that was so that's that's what I have
to say I think it was very well executed
yeah and I think pce Morgan got the
comeuppance um he deserved and of course
with basam musu had a different angle uh
and Subhan together it was a great great
com of interviews did you guys see the
new video about that Grandma being
released the so-called grandma's being
hurt and she was just you know talking
about it wasn't even that bad so this
brings me to a question this is
something that's been on my mind for a
while but you know arami tweeted out you
know it was kind of ironic but you
basically said that I secretly believe
that Piers Morgan is pro Palestinian but
he can't come out with it so that's why
he gets people like Muhammad hijab and
Bas him to kind of humiliate him live so
what do you what do you think about that
I don't think so I think he's um he he
actually is probably not convinced
ideologically but he knows the
implication of having an anti stance and
don't forget talk support is actually
owned by uh ruper Murdoch so I mean he's
got connections with um so on but
without going into anything that can get
us into litigation because you can you
can get done for defamation of car if
you go too far in this direction I'm not
sure if you know because you can you
know I'm not saying anything that could
uh could you know particularly what I am
saying
is about about an explicit connection
between the two figures but what I'm
saying is that it's clearly you know
people are saying other people are
saying certainly in the comments that
there's a connection there and there's a
monetary interest which which brings us
to and even people like Russell Brand
bro like he's always been leftwing he's
always been like he he's a soas guy as
well soas is one of the most leftwing
universities in the United Kingdom and
he was he's a graduate from there he's
he's leftwing all his life he hasn't
said a word of condemnation by Israel
people are playing their cards because
of two things money and because they
don't want to alienate certain members
of the right wing so someone like
Russell Brand he's now started to get
alt-right support because of as you know
like he's had interviews with Jordan
Peterson he's had interviews with
certain right-wing people Joe Rogan he's
not really rightwing and in fact he's
been much better on this but Russell
Brad hasn't come out as anything for
example so people are playing their
cards right and they're trying to make
sure they don't alienate certain
demographics but at the same time
they're not buying the bullet which
shows you that money and interest um is
inspiring people more so than ideology
and principles that's a good point I'm
glad you mentioned that because I think
it's very obvious that like you
mentioned these are very successful so
the reason he probably brought you on
and many others on is because he knew it
would do well he knew like 7 million
views for you in a few days 14 million
views in the next in the in the next day
in the next video like that's crazy but
on the note of of Pi and and some of the
things that he was saying um something I
found notable and this is something Ali
Dar pointed out he was like I don't do
hypotheticals he gave hypotheticals many
times he was like so what if I identify
as a black woman that's the the most
hypothetical type of
I had a friend of mine say um that he he
probably wouldn't uh he probably
wouldn't wouldn't enjoy those um
airplane safety guidelines if you
Travels by plane and they say all right
then so in the event of uh you know
emgen Landing you have to no no sorry
sorry sorry madam I don't do
hypothetical I don't want to know about
a Airline safety what have you yeah it
it was ridiculous it was obvious that he
was just trying to squirm his way out
but but you you mentioned why would they
invite um you know Muslims over to such
platforms um uh me and many other darts
have been been inviting such platforms
Sim similar to such and there's always
the motivation is they they you know and
I think M also say that they they
research you beforeand they ask you what
would you say to this what would you say
to that and then they they choreograph a
way to trap you to then uh expose you uh
or to uh uh show that you don't have an
argument attempt to show that you don't
have an argument but as I said I don't
think he was fully expecting Muhammad
hijab style and I think and I also
mentioned something else wanted to
mention something else which one thing I
actually greatly enjoyed was Muhammad
job's use of an analogy this is I didn't
give him this one he this is analogy
that heed I think was the best one he
said he said um you know saying that the
Palestinians just generally the
Palestinians are aggressors and the
Israelis are just defending themselves
right it's like saying that the victim
is the aggressive for defending herself
yeah that was and that was brilliant it
was a one line one of the only things
that no but it was it was good
nonetheless because you see you really
all that the Muslim does when you speak
the Huck on an unfair platform is yes
they they they try to control narrative
they'll cut you off they'll speak over
you yeah they'll do that when you're
making a good point right but there's
one thing that they can't stop right
which is you might get that brief moment
to say an excellent oneliner yeah right
and it might just only be a oneliner
yeah but you make it concise make it
Punchy and you just conveys the
narrative and bang and that was an
example of how he that a massive shot
got off in Morgan Studio people making
jumpers on one guy he made a jumper or
something like that like jumpers with
that quotation on you see did you
see subh Allah may Allah BL definitely
certainly having its effect 100% you
know something something that he
mentioned I keep hearing this talking
point it's a it's a matter of
proportionality what's a proportionate
response to me I don't think it's a
matter of proportion I think it's a
matter of principle like are are are we
willing as human beings to accept kill
of innocent men women children to get
out some enemy to me it's like if they
say yes like that's what did to an
extent and if they say no it's like
okay's doing that so why you not they're
condemning them I think it was on it was
answered um I remember Muhammad J said
to P like uh the response would be if
they did a military operation against
you and this or Brigade to be more
precise then you do a military operation
of your soldiers finding their soldiers
in a targeted targeted response right so
soldiers fight soldiers but saying well
we're just going to uh civilian
buildings and and this time not even
pretending to warn the Palestinian they
admit it even argue even said that we
will start hostages if you don't at
least warn the the the Palestinian
civilians in the buildings just give
them that the 10minute warning yeah
they're meant to but guess what didn't
execute any hostages regardless they
just made that as a because of the the
civilian dead so so uh it was brought up
in the P Morgan interview that look the
propor for response is if a criminal
does something bad you target the the
criminal with your special forces I know
it's more it's more risky for your
soldiers but soldiers are there to take
a for the civilians that's the whole
point of it yeah it's like they signed
up to the possibility of D on the field
so why why not send them to go do what
they signed up to do rather than just B
innocent people who who are trapped in
there because of you and people you you
threw in together yeah it's Collective
it's Collective punishment and at the
very least yeah and that that was
exposed and I said P Morgan just
couldn't couldn't defend that he was
just uh stumbling over uh his tongue I
said he was stumbling over his tongue he
lost his he lost his tongue lost his
marbles he lost his principles right and
only joking he doesn't have any
principles I was I was talking to sha
actually about his own experiences in
leban and um it's it's really incredible
how he was painting it out to me because
we have this this view that this thing
has just started now this stuff has been
going on in the Middle East for a very
long time do you mind sharing a bit of
what you told me about your own
experience Leon how do you compare that
with this in terms of the Civil War you
mean Bally well you know Subhan Allah
the Civil War in Lebanon was for 15
years really 75 to 90 and it was uh
similar were everywhere the whole
country was B there was militias on the
ground that basically really supported
to do lots of
anding really the most popular or the
most known one is the sa in 1982 if I'm
not mistaken where two camps full of
women elderly and civilians were just
literally put under a Siege by the
Israel so you see this was right this is
before the um the establishment of H you
witnessed you you were a witness to this
kind of behavior it was very young but
definitely it's recorded and there's
lots of uh human right organization that
documented the they used to take babies
and their heads in the wall this is this
what happened basically yeah is the time
basically invading Lebanon so forth
unbelievable so it's a continual pattern
isn't it oh definitely you know you made
a very interesting point you said if the
UN if these organizations are toothless
you know then like who really is going
to bring about any change what are we
going to do if the UN is a toothless
organization and that's a great point
because let's say isra does do this and
America backs him up who's going to stop
them really well I speaking to abdah and
thean he was giving a very good analogy
once again that I don't want to steal
from him in his presence I think that
would be a new low no which is the I
want to bring this to you which is the
the analogy you gave of the unruly child
Israel is the unruly child and you had a
very interesting analysis of that could
you bring that to the table and tell us
what you how you how You' put it oh okay
so um so yeah like like people have
often argued that um is puppet of
America or they argue that America's
puppet of is right but it doesn't work
quite like that um so America uses it to
project uh its power its interests
gather intelligence control the the the
region so it's better than just having
10 aircraft carries American aircraft
carries in the region but uh at the same
time then is America for obviously
getting weapons funding and also
intelligence benefits but also come um
having America come to its help if it
runs out of weapons or or what have you
like in 1973 they had to rely on
resupply of tanks and things from and
and jets from America otherwise they
would have they could have they would
have lost much more significantly okay
but isra is an unruly child right if it
has a father or sugar daddy you could
say giving it its you know it supplies
um it doesn't always do what America
wants right uh so America doesn't want
it to build settlements in the West Bank
because that antagonizes the Palestinian
antagonizes the Muslims in the region
makes it unstable and threatens the the
uh the the the governments in the region
which America would like to see
maintained yeah as as opposed to the
alternative where you know you get
uprisings by the people possibly in
Islamic governments Islamic governments
or maybe reuniting into one Islamic
government which is America's nightmare
scenario so America wants to stop this
antagonism because because it wants a
peace de between the Palestines and isra
because it doesn't care about sement
doesn't care about changing demographics
to a majority uh kind of Jewish
population on the whole state of
Palestine they don't care about this
project they they just want a military
there that does what they want right but
will have their objective right they
want the whole state of Palestine for
their their borders but they don't want
to be 50/50 Palestinian Arab and Jewish
they want it to be at least
80% um you know Palestinian um Arab and
sorry 20% Jewish 20% Arab Israeli and 8%
Jewish so they uh they are trying to
settle the rest of all the the rest of
the lands as much as possible and
they've always said it's very
consistently going back to Bening who
was the first prime minister of is so
they have that so there's this this's
this kind of balancing act or tension
between is foreign policy and um kind of
domestic policy and American foreign
policy and so yeah they unruly trial
because sometimes like they want to bomb
Gaza America doesn't want them to bomb
Gaza that so much because because it
causes bad PR their own voters will say
and taxpayers will say to the American
government why are you supporting this
are we paying for this what you know so
they they sent two aircraft carriers
into the region America sent two
aircraft carriers now they was the
excuse was that we're protecting um is
from potential attacks from his one
aircraft Carri you don't even need it is
has his own aircraft it could do it
could it could B how many how many
aircrafts does an aircraft carrier hold
about 65 70 uh roughly in the region dep
depending on on on the type of roughly
in the region that it's it's it's it's
equipped to do most tasks right one
aircraft carry is sufficient even if it
didn't have an Air Force One aircraft
car is sufficient to to B as many
targets as it wants in in Lebanon or in
Syria and so I mean Iran's on the other
side's not really going to get directly
involved but you know and and or G if he
wanted to right but two aircraft
carriers it's
over right so why is it sending two
aircraft carriers right now my um
hypothesis don't I don't do hyal brother
yeah yeah oh no not the
hypothetical um is basically that uh
they're basically just making a
statement to is uh calm down on the on
the bomb on the Gaza bomb and like you
know uh calm down don't go don't commit
an actual G there because it makes it
very difficult for us so they do a
little slap you know slap on the risk to
their unruly child so this is the the
the back and forth kind of between you
know uh surrogate father and and unruly
unruly son so yeah that's that's how to
I think better to understand what's
going on because I said America wants is
to be a good obedient Outpost for its
own interests but but there design want
to to fulfill their demographic goals
and their political goals to make so on
a PR level or po level like if we push
America so I mean obviously not push
America but the the public opinion if it
changes then you can see how everything
can be connected to policy making
because you said you were saying if
their own populations are saying for
example why is our taxes being spent on
this which brings us to what we can be
doing as Muslims which is getting
engaged in the information War like for
example a video like this m i mean
I'm sure they're going to be subscribing
to this channel now as a means of and
and spreading the video and commenting
and liking and these kind of things CU
this this is the kind of not seriously
on a serious level it edifies the people
and um it allows us to put off our
narrative forward yeah you know next
week we have Dr Omar on the podcast too
and we want to talk deeper about this
issue too you know and you see his
Instagram he's using the platform
unapologetically to really doing well
with this he's really doing well with it
you know and and he's not really
cowering down like a lot of people are
afraid of these things I think that and
she you know as Muslims we have a
responsibility of what verifying
everything right it it's as Muslims we
have to practice what we preach but I
think this time the mainstream media has
actually gone too far I think as brother
Tom Fen was saying in a podcast that
they overplayed their hand this time and
now people are actually waking up
non-muslims too kufar and they're seeing
it for what it is what do you think
about that well I wanty to quickly
illustrate that the the aparti South
Africa the Western governments had very
positive relations with them you know F
fat
primee marget fat on the UK America they
all actually uh supported the government
until there was a massive sea change in
the in the the people around the world
that their view the pressure that was
put actually made them change theire
their um stance on it because the the
most important the most powerful
political force there is is public
opinion always has been right so anyway
sorry that was just a little you were
asking the I wanted to get his take as
well on this actually what did you think
yeah yeah know I was thinking basically
while Abdullah was speaking look the
issue is is um I come from an IT
background okay so YouTube Facebook all
these platforms is it takes literally
few clicks and and and and all of us
together can be shut down but we need to
understand that like it's very important
that it's if we're going to rely on one
piece of the puzzle and it's very
important one piece of the puzzle media
is very important but we need to have
plan a plan B plan C Plan D for just the
media but more importantly understand
that it's a one piece of of many things
like you know you can't rally people and
and and and and and change a nation just
basically through media it has to
basically media coupled with grassroot
just at least those two pieces together
so kind of like you can't walk in one
leg can you so you need basically both
legs together and to be honest basically
add the third recipe the third piece of
the recipe which is basically having
some of the uh the power Brokers in the
Muslim world who should become on your
side so there's there's many things to
cause change and media is definitely one
of them one of the best tools for for
awar Wess I take you back to basically
the the American Civil War the Americans
the George Washingtons and the Thomas
Jeffersons they they didn't just
basically form from Heavens or just pop
up out of nowhere they spent 15 years
yeah in ideological intellectual media
based uh spreading of information and
and and ideology and propaganda within
the 13 colonies until they've been able
to Rally the people but in addition to
the media which used to be newspapers
and and op EDS and and leaflets
they organized people they used to be
called The Brothers of Liberty and the
sisters of Liberty you see what I'm
saying in literally
in for studies for for for people who
were ready to sacrifice you can't
basically have 13 col of just civilians
who are just distracted with
entertainment you're going to kick out
the British the biggest empire in the
world there were lots of basically work
that was done by the Jefferson and the
Washingtons and and the Adams of the
Revolution to be able to push back and
when the time came basically and you
know Britain set set that you know
famous tax law it was the people were
ready under the guide and and the
leadership of the Jefferson and the
Washingtons to mobilize and move and to
basically push back so it's very
important to study Revolutions in
general when we want to do PR and PO for
a a goal right we're not because we're
not just here to sell basically coffee
right so we want to mobilize the um we
want to basically create change and
change has many components definitely
one of them and one of the most
important is Media there has to be a
consistent message that can unify the um
and give them political awareness when
we don't have political awareness we can
just basically create emotions and
that's dangerous because we with
emotions you're going to see response
and you're going to think that this
response is mobilization it's not it's
just a knee-jerk
reaction so that's very important it's a
great point I want to ask on one about
one portion of the recipe which is you
know working as a collective working as
a group you'll see and this this is
small in the big scale of things but I
think it's pretty significant nowadays
for a lot of average people they'll see
like McDonald's and Starbucks their
stock has plummeted because everyone's
boing them you know so for us it's the
grand scheming things not a big deal but
when people work as a collective it's
like okay I'm not giving my $7 to
Starbucks a week but then you know
thousands of people do that and then it
actually has a big effect so how do we
mobilize as as a collective how can we
work together to accomplish a goal like
stopping this you know if I make comment
basically that marketing especially
nowadays basically works on psychology
to to create an a reaction right like
your consumer
psychology the the the the the copy of
the text the imagery the video the
message how you're projecting it into
into the user is is is is is you know
where within an IT world is basically
generating a click right that's what we
do for life for for business me and Ramy
work together so but it's not a click
that we're trying to do basically here
what you're trying to do is mobilize
people in a structured way to create
create organized work it needs lots of
uh you know uh steps after the the
initial message so maybe both mamad and
and abdah can comment on that like what
what does it take to basically after the
click we create videos we create media
we we Hye people out that look we need
to do something okay people people going
to say look I get it what's next I'm I
shared your clip is this is this my role
and is this is this what we're asking
them to do because is that enough we
already said it's not it's not enough
but what is the next step I think just
looking at the micro scale in the
community everyone has the resources and
the tools and the equipment to become a
Creator I think far too many people are
caught up with consuming than creating
not everyone can be a Creator but I feel
like anyone can it's a good point man
there's a lot of people nowadays that
can you know doesn't have to be your
face on the camera as well you can make
your own website you can do you can have
your own groups you can speak to your
colleagues all of that stuff is is is
being a knowledge producer in a sense
and an edifier an educator
and uh it's absolutely right yeah see
when we go on your your YouTube your bio
I remember reading this a while ago I
don't know if you changed it but it says
something like arguing the case for
Islam or educating the case for
something simple like that and that's
honestly why we started the podcast two
years ago Mei and ano and we were
getting wasw bro right before starting
it like are we ready are we not and we
were like we're not Scholars we're not
sh we're not even uh student of
knowledge hardly so how do we get to
that point where we can do it we can't
so we might as well document our journey
and use our platform form while we
simultaneously increase our knowledge
and learn there's no perfect time to
start do you get what I mean
so you know you know disseminate my
message even if it's one a and so I mean
you don't need to have some of the most
effective people I've seen in dawa are
not Scholars and not students of
knowledge in fact some of the the
students of knowledge and Scholars have
been the least effective in dawa I've
seen because they just don't have the
interpersonal
skills so it's it's good to have
knowledge and all that kind of things
but you don't need uh a baz to kill
bunny rabbit like if you don't need to
have a rocket launcher to to kill an ant
and so really in truly what we're doing
is if you're if you're trying to bring
people to Islam trying and bring people
to a basic thing you only need to know a
a few very important facts and the same
thing with this conflict if you want to
bring people to your way of thinking in
regards to for example the aparte state
of all you need is a basic a few basic
facts about the apart St about the
racial discrimination laws about this
and that and you can make the case and
so it's I think sometimes we over
complicate things one of the strongest
things that we have to our disposal as a
Muslim people is our numbers we are the
youngest demographic in terms of
religion according to Pure research
we're the youngest religion in the world
and that's why they saying 2050 2000
we're going to be you know the number
one religion of place ands in terms of
numbers of adherance and followers and
so if every one of us did I mean not
even all of us if a big chunk of us just
had one
kind of direction that we were going in
and worked in One Direction and produced
content and produced knowledge and done
dawa and done all these kind of things
even if it's not every single one of us
even if we were able to get 30% for the
sake of argument or 40% or 10% it would
create significant demographic shifts
and changes in public opinion if I if I
may add one thing so so um there's three
things that we need right
awareness uh organization right
and mobilization so you use content to
create awareness that's basically where
the content creation comes in comes
handy through relationships and
connection connectivity with with your
followers and subscribers and and in
general your community can call it if
you want to call it that's where you
create organization right like you
organize as a team right and then you
and then leadership is used to mobilize
so there are three steps and there's
ways there's methods for each step right
it's a Content creation for awareness
but we stop if we stop with the
awareness we're not going we're not
going to succeed after awareness you
need organization how do you organ
relationship building you see what I'm
saying you connect with your subscribers
you connect with your followers and you
and then you you you create teams
through through that relationships and
then leadership leadership is what's
needed that again going back to the
American Civil War I'm very like sub
fascinated by it because it was very
successful it's the only country in the
planet on the planet that push back the
British
Empire everything else is facade
everything is like really like a hoax or
more or less really but the Americans
when they unified the 13 colonies
through these three steps they've been
they've been able to push back the
British Empire so today if we want to
basically liberate our lands liberate
our nation have free self-determination
which is our right even from a un
Charter Charter of right perspective
that we have to do the three things and
definitely basically I3 is not the the
best at the first one from a perspective
of media we're trying to Muhammad was
trying to give us lots of pointers and
Abdullah one of our research uh
researchers here trying to help out with
that inshallah we're trying to solidify
that but we have a little bit more
experience basically within the
mobilization piece sorry the the the
organization P that was well said this
reminds me of when I was first you know
becoming practicing getting on Dean so
to speak and that was around the time
that I met Rami and believe it or not
one of the First videos that he showed
me was this debate that you had with I
think it was David wood it was the
inperson Oxford debate wasn't Oxford
that was New York that was New York New
York York okay he then showed me this uh
other video about humorus with Lawrence
Krauss yeah and when I watched those
those videos for the first time in my
life I had this preconceived notion that
you were either scientific and
intelligent or you were religious you
were Islamic right and when I saw
speakers like yourselves I realized that
you can read both and then I see all
these da today talking about how we have
the truth why are are we on the
backpedal why are we on the defensive so
why do you think Muslims today have
become very weak and almost apologetic
shy about their Islamic
identity well look I mean it's difficult
I don't know in the west what the
analysis is but I've seen different
communities react in different ways like
for example going to Philadelphia a lot
of the African-American communities I
don't I wouldn't categorize them for
example as on the back foot in any way
like I think that temperamentally
because they had the Civil Rights kind
of back ground and they understand that
you have a dominant ethic or you have a
dominant ideology and then you it's it's
okay it's culturally acceptable to go
against that and in fact the dominant
population or and or the dominant ethic
or those who are Elites they don't want
the best for you and therefore you know
put the up to them kind of thing so
that's more it's very popular in certain
African-American cultures and therefore
there isn't I don't think in those
areas uh that sense of okay we need to
acqu s or subordinate ourselves to the
dominant ethic in more subcontinental
cultures and Arab cultures I have seen
that a little bit more sometimes and
it's not with all Arab cultures and not
all subcontinental cultures but in some
aspect in some parts of their population
I think a lot of the reason why that's
the case is because of
colonialism it's it's kind of like the
postcolonial trauma don't forget you
know you know the British and the French
and these kinds of countries they went
into our countries and they subdued uh
our grandparents effectively so we go
ask our El to what extent is part of
that the attitude of subjugation have we
inherited it it's the internalized
Colonial mindset yeah I it's not with
all of us certainly like there's some
people that you know within India for
example there are some tribes I've met
that are very very disagreable to any
kind of colonial but some people have
met in India that are complete opposite
to that to be honest with you especially
U BJP supporters who are not Muslim I've
seen that they have an overcompensatory
A lot of them attitude towards Western
Behavior m in Algeria for example if you
go I feel like it's very disagreeable I
mean in terms of repelling of colonial
uh belief system is because they know
that the dominant say French at that
time when they are next the country they
have stories from their grandparents and
their great-grandparents or their
parents even that this is what they've
done to us and they've killed this and
so there's this feeling of you're trying
to twist my arm and I know what you're
trying to do it's part of the cultural
Collective reality in a country like
that so it's there's not one size forit
all it's not one analysis for the whole
Muslim world
um and certainly even within those
Nations that I mentioned and these
cultures I mentioned there's different
attitudes of course and different
temperaments but a lot of it is if
there's one thing that's going to
be the main one of the main reasons for
this I think is the colonial experience
and when you subjugate a people it's
difficult for those people not only to
come out of that subjugation but then to
think that they are what they have to
offer is better than the colonial Master
it's very difficult to to come out
number one to unfree yourself from the
chain the mental colonization and that's
one thing that's difficult and then
after that to think that what I have is
better than what the colonizer has
especially considering that nowadays the
ideological Elites their technological
um you know Masters effectively they the
a lot of the inventions have happened
has happened in the Western World the
last 100 years obviously this is after
the invasion of electricity or the um
how electricity was after this um and
after the Industrial Revolution after
the co was found in in in Britain and so
on lots of other factors um discover the
AG of Discovery lots of other factors
historical factors which led to this
nevertheless you had the Scientific
Revolution you had the indust revolution
um and these things facilitated the west
and being able to be technological uh
superpowers hegemonic superpowers um and
so now they're technological Masters
they're scientific Masters they've got
militaries stronger than our militaries
by by number of um you know war planes
and and military equipment and nuclear
weapons and so on but K young said it
right Carl Young obviously being one of
the psychoanalysts he said that that the
West are technological Giant and moral
midgets and what we need to understand
we need to delineate between those two
realities yes they're technological
they've got fantastic architecture and
fantastic we we can take that we can
even copy that there's no shame in taken
from the scientific and technological
advancements of the western world or
other than the Western World just like
there was they were Shameless and doing
so so doing in the Renaissance period
for example for the Muslim people
there's no shame in that the problem is
being able to delineate what we can take
from the west and what we can accept
from them what we respect them for even
you can say we respect the fact that the
western civilization has done this we
accept that they've done accomplishment
and at the same time maintaining our
moral sense of to be
hity no no we we feel that our morality
is a superior morality right so you you
to realize that the West is a
technological Giant by moral is
the first Diagnostic and then once
you've realized that then you can
effectively take the good and leave the
bad but then that has a meaning now the
ideological stuff is the bad especially
those ideological stuff direct conflict
with the Islamic belief system things
like second way feminism which is a
slippery slope as you guys know you done
you do great work I have to say I mean
I've seen some of your videos I have
praised everyone except for you I mean
mashallah some of the stuff that you do
really good and you relatable and you're
connecting with the the the audiences in
1835 in a way that you were talking
about students of knowledge only some of
them can wish to do so but one of the
things that you guys have been
instrumental in being able to push
within Islamic spaces and even outside
of them is actually the incoherence of
feminism and that actually strengthens
it's in effect doing what we're we're
talking about here it strengthens the
Muslim identity makes people proud to be
Muslim so feminism liberalism and these
kinds of isms once you are able to
disengage from those and deconstruct
those and diminish those in your own
mind and decolonize yourself from those
then you can proceed to uh you know
reestablishing yourself as a
non-colonized
individual first first and foremost may
Allah bless you immensely and make us as
you see us I mean something that that
all the points you mention remind me of
is this idea that the medium is the
message when you look at uh this is this
is popular in with culture media when
you look at the government the reason
you know their messaging and their
beliefs are well perceived is because of
who they are what they have what they
have accomplished and I think that also
um that also is true for what you
mentioned with us because we're younger
people we can connect to a younger
audience I think because you're you're
you're a big and very confident well
spoken uh intellectual you can appeal to
nothing that's too many worthy words no
no it's okay that's enough for you I
need to make I'm going to make that my
ringtone alarm bro make sure that tell
me the time stamp and I'll just pretend
to be watching this video I'm going to
no no no I'm going to bring my kids into
the room my wife I'm going to say
everyone sit down let's just see what
these guys have to say oh look oh my God
they're saying some really interesting
St Allah bless you but um because you
have these
traits as Abdullah Andi it's it's it's
very digestible for a lot of people so
what would you say to reach the the vast
audience of people that we have are the
important traits to walk the walk or
walk the talk I guess should say I want
to start by actually redirecting that
question I want him to give his two
cents on and then I'll answer that
question that's okay okay well
definitely the number one is is courage
like you have to to to Project Courage
to the masses because this is a disease
that's you know stifling us people are
scared to to to be themselves people are
scared to be Muslim people are scared to
identify as Muslim people are scared to
to stand up for their rights see what
I'm saying like this is very important
while I was traveling with Imam Tom one
of the ladies on the on the uh on the uh
Kiosk for the uh airplane she she wanted
wanted our IDs even though we didn't
want to check in we were already checked
in she's like well no no you're here so
can I see your ID please so anyway I
gave her that one and then with with our
friend saat here she wanted to basically
put in his handheld uh this tag it's
like you paid for it so when it came my
turn I'm like no I don't want it she's
like no you have to have it I'm like no
I don't have to have it you know and and
I'm I'm not checking in here basically
and and get off of me basically you see
I'm saying like people are not using
people are used to basically stand in
line straight do what they're told and
we need to have this rebellious uh
mindset not to rebel against everything
because see you have to push back the
system is there to sub make you subdued
so you have to Project Courage number
two you have to project an inspiration a
dream to the people if you want to if
you want to create awareness uh and then
basically after that mobilization what
are you trying to tell people you have
to give them something super clear
that's why Allah in the Quran what he
say says mu about the Quran multiple
places see why because the message has
to be clear and the message has to be
large gigantic a dream that people
can it can make people go Sleepless he's
like you know when you have an interview
for a great job you can't sleep that day
or that night right why because you're
so excited you're so excited like oh my
gosh when I have that job and you're so
stressed about it why aren't we stressed
about Jenna Jenna is the best thing ever
but we're not thinking about it you see
I'm saying what about Jenna's millions
millions of levels are you thinking
about what's the top level how can I get
to the top but nobody's speaking about
that today in this end of times there's
people who have who will be with the in
the same crew in the day of judgment
there's few seats that Allah with his
infinite Mercy he left few seats of that
category of of sahaba lookalikes I call
them for the end of times for you and us
and me are we gonna go and say I want to
be part of that I want that chair I want
that seat you know I'm gonna buy that
ticket but see you have to pay the price
for that
see I'm saying did the prophet not tell
us to make Dua specifically for gentle F
exactly so you're not saying to be
aggressive but be assertive and to kind
of put your foot down and make sure
there's no Injustice but this whole
this idea that you're saying be
courageous a lot of people lack this do
you think it comes from lack of
competence because we don't want to just
fake it till we make it why do you think
most Muslims are not courageous well you
know Subhan Allah it's because you it's
a tough situation we're living in a
scary situation that's why when Allah in
the Quran describes the theah of Allah
says they don't there's no fear uh about
them and they don't fear anybody except
Allah and they they don't get sad nobody
should be sad about them whatever
whatever they trials they go through
because they're G to be the winners and
they would not be
sad describes him says they don't get
afraid when people get afraid and they
don't feel sad and depressed when when
people feel sad and depressed see I'm
saying they don't have that feeling of
helplessness there's always a way if
there's a problem there's always a
solution if there's a an ill if there's
a sickness or ill there's always a cure
right so we have to believe that it's
possible the minute you you don't feel
it's possible you're going to try what
would you say um just in response to
that like um Costa mat who was the who's
the uh trainer of Mike Tyson he stated
that like when he's defining what
courage is he said it's not courage is
not having no fear it's having fear but
acting despite the fear the and he says
that you know the difference between the
hero and the coward is the action and I
for me that's one of the most powerful
definitions of Courage the reason why I
think what you said I think you hinted
to a good part of why people don't have
courage in certain areas it's to do with
competence I think that is the case I
mean competence and courage are two
sides of the same coin if you consider
the things you're courageous in doing
like for example many people will be
finding it very difficult to to be on a
stream like you are in front of hundreds
of thousands maybe even more Millions
now combined like your channel has
millions of views so many people if they
knew that they were going to be speaking
in front of hundreds of thousands of
people they find it hard now if you ask
yourself what made you like you're
sitting mallah very composed asking very
articulate questions knowing when to
interject knowing I'm praising the guy
um like are you micro analyzing us both
of you I'm saying like you guys do a
good job right so but and you you do a
good job and because you know you're
competent about something you don't fear
too much the consequences so you can
know that if you set set it up you make
your diet before you started as you did
and then you and you can ask a question
so competence and courage are two sides
of the same coin if if you take me now
to mountain climbing and put a harness
on me and say climb this mountain and
get me a seven or eight-year-old who's
done mountain climbing or wall climbing
that seven or eight year-old is going to
be way more courageous than I am in
climbing that war because he's done it
way more times than I have so Expo this
was referred to in Psychology exposure
therapy exposing yourself to the area
where you're afraid and actually trying
to build internal resilience that is how
to do it um and so the people in Gaza
now that for me they're the most brave
people on the face of the Earth or at
least some of the most brave people in
the why because they're confronted with
some of the most extreme situations and
they have to develop the internal
mechanism so I look I Look to them
people like that for inspiration so long
story short the point is if you want to
become more courageous you have to take
the plunge you have to expose yourself
to the thing that makes you scared and
you have to continuously do that until
you get to a point where you feel
competent enough calm enough um if
you're like confident enough to complete
that task and courage is subject
specific
for when for example many people who
you'd consider to be very very brave
people they may be afraid of certain
animals or rat or cockroach or certain
thing because they haven't had the
exposure to these animals or for other
psychological
reason doesn't mean they're
cowards so what makes somebody a coward
like for example I I watch these people
sometimes that jump from building to
building I I watch I actually follow
some of them on
Instagram and this guy he jumped on this
kind of like you know the lampost he
jumped literally from the top of
building yeah and he jumped and he he
grabbed it and he fell I was did you see
this I was thinking this guy's a crazy
guy man I said I would never ever do
that I said there's only one situation
where my life is in danger or my
children's life I do something like that
but apart from that I could never
imagine doing this for fun does that
make me a coward or make you a coward or
anyone no it doesn't make you a coward
so what make in a general sense what
makes you a coward because the prophet
wasam told
us that the the worst thing in a man is
to to have is to be a miserly person and
to be a coward so what is it to be a
coward then it to be a coward is not to
be able to defend yourself to speak the
truth and to defend your
family that's why do you know in a
general sense you know it from the
Islamic
perspective well not all sports are the
same unless you're making it as like you
know a football soccer player if you're
a fantastic soccer player but then you
have someone who can fight
pound-for-pound the guy who can fight is
probably better than you because you're
not going to be doing kick ups when
someone punches you in the
face do you see what I mean with all due
respect knowing how to fight should be a
prerequisite for every man in the world
because without it you won't know how to
defend yourself or your family so you
would be a coward if you couldn't defend
yourself or your family you wouldn't be
a coward if you if someone put you in
the 90th minute of World Cup match and
you couldn't score a goal or you or you
froze because it was too much
pressure the point is from the Islamic
perspective you got the word cowardly or
jaban is connected
or if you feel like this is connected to
the um the lack of fulfillment of
certain objectives that the Shar came to
so for example Allah in the
Quran says in the
[Music]
Quan says that when an Ayah comes down
and it's got a decisive command to go
and fight you'll see the ones who have a
Allah look what Allah says the ones who
have a disease in their heart so this
kind of fear is referred to as a disease
it's not even referred to as cowardly
Allah doesn't even say coward the ones
whove got cowardly it's a disease in
their
heart they're looking at you as if
they're going to die and then it says
it's better for them means it's
prioritized for them to go and fight and
then it
says that you you have to obey Allah
so clearly when it comes to defending
yourself if you don't do it you're a
coward according to sh if you can't
defend your wife if she you're letting
her get humil you're coward according to
Shar if you can't um these are the
things that will make you coward
according to Shar if I can't if I can't
climb a wall like there's one guy who
used to climb a thing without the
harness and he fell I don't know the
guy's name he went on the mountain
climbed it all up and he fell near from
the top his whole body got mashed up he
was in the hospital for 3 four years
guess what you done he went back to the
same mountain and climbed it again now
and he had to do reconstructions and all
that tell me now if he says to be look
I'm more of a man than you because I can
climb that mountain I say no you're
not that's not the for me yes I accept
you're more Brave in this context but it
doesn't make you more of a man than me
everything you just laid out right now
bro all the traits that Allah and Islam
will I guess hold to high regard the
West will use shaming tactics and call
that toxic masculinity or misogyny yeah
of course so do you think that one of
the tactics that the West has used is to
almost redefine commity to keep West as
well it's like you know this left wing
it's a segment from the West a lot of
the West are pushing back from this
nonsense like the tradcons yeah a lot of
them um I mean in a sense we're a part
of the West and we're pushing back do
you know what I mean but certainly the
you know the red pill movement is is a
massive I mean look at Andrew Tate he's
getting massive popularity now in the
west he's a western figure and look at
the English boys in in England they're
all following him and saying yes and you
guys know that you've communicated with
his best friends and you know him very
well and all that kind of stuff so
there's a sthe of people that just
reject that and even forget about that I
mean even in the more in the center
people are rejecting it more and more
the point is they can call it what they
want to call it you know at the end of
the day you know we shouldn't be afraid
of any label whether it's toxic
masculinity if you want to assert our
dominance or our position in families or
whatever is if we're going to live our
lives afraid what people will label us
then we're going to be paralyzed by the
labels and the stigma we just have to go
on with it
really I have a further point about I
think um cardist is related to one's
idea of what is necessary right so if uh
many people think well I don't want to I
don't want to put my neck out um and SPO
my my purpose in life which is to acrw a
comfortable job you know get get money
for holidays uh you know so I can I can
get married and all this kind of stuff
will be endangered if I mely just speak
out one moment on one issue which I as
an individual I don't think I can make
much change well they see it like that
of course they say it's not necessary
they might even say it's unwise maybe
people someone's parents have said to
someone else this is unwise I know you
feel very strongly about people on Gaza
you you smile like the right with
recognition but one one's parents
because the parents they try to take his
parents
[Laughter]
no I'm saying there's too many people in
my family that I know they're like bro
why you speaking up about this they're
going to Target you yeah because because
their argument is that it's it's not
bravery it's recklessness fullart yeah
yeah yeah and and that actually
hamstrings a lot of um Muslims and their
desire to make a change of thinking I
won't make much of a change yes uh by
sticking my my neck as one individual
I'll get i'll get identified blacklisted
for something maybe my career's over
maybe my job's over what have you and
those those that multiplied by the
thousands millions leads to a collective
silence okay abut one one thing one
thing I noticed about you know people
that live in a part of gangs or in
Rundown areas yes right is um you know
you might say they're very materialistic
they want to just get you know like nice
car and money and wealth and so on so
forth but let's say if someone says Okay
um you know I'm going to uh I'm going to
humiliate you if I if you let me
humiliate you I'll let you live and you
can continue living um or if not I'll
kill you right so the gang most gang
person gang members whatever would say I
prefer to die right or they or you they
say you put a gun their their face and
they act unscared they have they're very
scared yeah but they act unscared and
you know why is because they realize
that being your reputation being
destroyed and you you known as a let's
say a weakling there's there more more
colorful words they' use right is is not
life yeah cuz no one will respect you
everyone will treat you you uh like like
like you are a weakly I'm it's using the
word weakling maybe P animus as
someone has been popularized as an Old
English word um so like you no one will
respect you also like going to prison
right if people know that you're
basically weak you're not willing to
fight some bigger guy bullies you and
he's bigger and if you fight him you're
going to get beaten up probably really
you're going to lose yeah but most
people will say well I have to if they
tried to bully me I have to fight back
I'm going to get beaten up but at least
I get respected I have limits yeah yeah
even though but someone could say oh but
if I fight back I'll get beaten up and
you know I'll get bruises and I might
you know I might have like cuts and
broken bones and I don't want that so
best to accept the humiliation but in
the long run ends up being worse so it's
because musl many Muslims think it's not
necessary Shakespeare they're not
they're not brave what did he say that
um the coward dies a million deaths yeah
because every time you get humiliated
like that it's unbelievable it's like
you're dying as you over and over again
if I made a basically like explain why
did Allah in the Quran say it's the
disease of the
heart what he say he
says meaning basically none of you
should basically stop saying the truth
because saying the truth will not make
your your death closer a single second
nor will basically take away any of your
risk and when you don't believe this is
believe in the this is believe in the
Unseen so it's if you don't believe in
that it's dis in the heart you see what
I'm saying when you understand that if
you're with Allah subh nobody can harm
you unless Allah wants that for you
because he knows with his infinite
wisdom that this is good for you because
see people basically unfortunately one
of the biggest I think disease of the
heart in the world today is and not just
today all the time basically is link or
or or linking e harm with evil and
linking you know pleasure so basically
every single harm that you go through
through you just consider it evil it's
because it's pain right it's a pain it's
a signal right so there's I call them
PMP Pleasure and Pain right so pleasure
is supposed to be good and and pain is
supposed to be evil and that's wrong you
need to break that in your head if you
don't break that in your head your a is
is actually has is a shaky and that's
that's what what it means basically you
have disease in the heart heart means
basically your belief system and which
impacts your emotions and the emotions
impact your behavior but let's discuss
that maybe in different like when you go
to the gym the pain that you feel is
good for
you of Z it's exactly exactly exactly
100% the bully The Bullying thing you
were talking about it reminds me when I
went to uh brother hijab Channel over
here and I clicked on most viewed videos
just out of curiosity and I see this
iPod Touch quality video and it said
when bullies get bullied oh yes yes so
how do you think about that today would
you be in that same situation yeah
absolutely no doubt I mean I Tred to
restrain myself there's a like you know
the The Virtue essics um kind of thing
that you alluded to before and I do I do
kind of like it to be honest this
helenistic thing which is written by
Aristotle called the nican ethics a book
and he and he does this kind of like two
um points of the extreme and then you
have them golden mean so you've got for
example by the way Aristotle considered
uh bravery to be the most important
virtue because through it everything
else can get done okay and he was like
okay you've got two you got two things
you got full hardness is a full
hardiness or we can say rashness on the
one hand then you got cowardice on the
other in the middle you have the golden
mean which is
bravery now
it's very difficult to get the middle of
each one of those things but with with
with bravery I would rather be rash than
cowardly this makes sense like sometimes
you know when you make a decision for
example if I'm with my wife in the
street or with my child in the street my
daughter and someone approaches and I
sense that there's antagonism I sense
that he may assult attack now let's say
for example I think it's 20% that
there's a chance that this
person something's going to happen I'd
rather that situation I'd rather be rash
than um I'd rather be rash than cowardly
so I'd rather overreact here than
underreact so the point is is with with
an issue like the Palestine issue or a
big issue where it's the stakes are
extremely high using the time the term
wisdom to try and temper someone's
natural reaction is pushing them to a
deficiency which is actually on balance
and as an aggregate worse than the uh
the the Surplus here cuz if you have a
surplus and you're rash now rashness is
not a good thing and be very clear and
the prophet sallam he actually warned
against
it is actually hastiness and rashness is
from the devil there's all kinds of
and actually the human being is created
in this manner from rashness or
hastiness or whatever yeah however so
it's not good thing in the Shar but it's
better than
cice so on certain issues I would rather
overreact than underreact and as a man
and I say as a man especially because
the prophet
said in the man the worst thing in the
man is to be a coward it's better for
him to be so-called unwise according to
these people than to be uh rash honestly
look at the UFC fighters how many of
them are 6'7 no one is in the UFC is my
height you're 6' seven yeah no no one is
but look at how many champions have you
had the others height if height was a
barometer for Success how many world
champions have you had this I would be
one of the tallest do you know what I
mean people in the UFC it's not it's not
about height it's not about in fact you
can argue and this is I can make the
case the prophet was not if it was if
was such a great thing then why the
Propet was not the tallest man he was
he's he was actually wide and
mesomorphic in frame he wasn't that he
wasn't that tall that's number one and
number two if you look at most Combat
Sports you'll find that the majority of
Champions are actually anything between
5 foot 10 to 6'2 so you don't think when
you're out with the wife and theid the
only exception to that is kickboxing not
even more type but kickboxing there's a
there's a height disparity there are
lots of tall people because there's
reach but Freestyle Wrestling is not the
case GRE R wrestling is not the case MMA
is not the case boxing is not the case
510 is even a little bit even I think
it's lower than that yeah I mean for I'm
talking about heavyweight now the
heavweight Champions they're not like 6'
five 6' a lot of them mik Tyson is a 5
fo 5 fo 10 for example so what I'm
saying is that it's it's never to do
with that um even if you're if if you're
smaller in in size you're not a
heavyweight there are many sports that
can allow you I mean John danaha he put
it is one of the most prolific Brazilian
jiu-jitsu specialist in the way probably
the most actually right now as a coach
of course I don't want to step on rer
Gracie's toes he's he's he's top guy as
well I mean in terms of the ghee but in
terms of nogee John Don is the best um
of course faras Zab you've met him of
course we've spoken to him he's his
student by the way so yeah faras Zab is
John danah has student so John DNA had
teaches GSP as well and so on and he
said the following thing and he it's one
of his podcasts with Lex fredman and it
makes perfect sense and if you know this
you'll know this and it applies to us in
the um in the Palestine situation as
well so this is going to be an
interesting connection he said you don't
he his thing is he believes in leg
locks he teaches his students how to get
the the knee and break the knee
effectively leg locks break your knee
that's what they do they fracture your
knee he said look John Dan has saying
the
following he's saying you don't need to
incap incapacitate the entire body if
you got a big man all you need to do is
get rid of his knee and his whole body
becomes incapacitated amazing point you
know and so what I'm saying to you is as
a smaller man there are in in Brazilian
jiujitsu in in in in MMA in general you
have a lot of smaller set men that can
actually beat bigger men pound-for-pound
even if it's called absolute category
you get the big man he's 120 kilos and
you get a 75 kilogram man the 75
kilogram man will be the favorite and he
will
win Mario Garcia for example being the
prime example of that he who's some
people say he's pound power for pound
number one Gordon uh Ryan for example
he's not he's he's big he is big but
he's not huge 6' one he's destroying
everyone any size get at s foot man it
doesn't matter he'll he'll take his knee
but I just say that it's funny that he
going on to height I mean yeah who are
the our enemies I mean like Ben Shapiro
look how short he
is
yeah short in morals as well as stature
and uh and is this is this the person
that we're afraid of that you have to be
a certain and so on although I have
noticed that okay you're 6' seven but
like myself Ali
da I'm 6'2 basically almost 63 right we
all C quite High that's actually just a
coincidence shortest person you but but
despite our height um physical height is
not the not a prerequisite that's a very
good point because I mean obviously
there's a kind of a rash example because
but if you look at Floyd Mayweather
versus Logan Paul Logan is giant
compared to the guy probably double his
weight
he's huge right he still got boded
pretty bad if if Logan Paul fought him
as a as a that be different he wrest I
think he should beat him absolutely I
agree if he's allowed to wrestle cuz
he's a wrestler he's a wrestler as well
yeah I agree 100% but the same is true
with with armies you know like how is it
the Muslims defeated huge
armies he was a strategist he knew how
to get out them yeah I heard once that
he actually just made it seem like there
were more
reinforcements we have to wrap up with
first but like if I feel like abdah you
would have a lot to say on this matter
so please in encourage us on this I
mean um I think he's one of the best
best generals of all time not um not
just for one particular Victory but for
multiple he even beat the Muslim Army
you know um he was very creative and he
never let limited resources get in the
way if he was limited resources against
a superior opponent he' think what
creative plan can I get can I invent
that would allow the conditions for
victory you know and this and this we
need to think of as well and this comes
from a firm belief again going back to
disease of the heart what does Allah say
in the Quran
says it is an obligation Upon Us Allah
set an obligation upon
himself to make the Believers Victorious
so when we have limited resources we
should just always believe that we can
do it when M was followed by blocked all
the land and there was just SE in front
of him his people says we we're
definitely we're dead guys it's over
what did M say
by the way is not just basically no is
like push back and no is like no no
you're wrong and no it's like a double
thing emphasiz emphasized right he says
no Allah's with us so definitely Allah's
going to guide us how it was all blocked
and the sea was split you see what I'm
saying but we have to believe in that if
we don't believe in that it's just a
problem and before we we close I want to
introduce one term into the vernacular
right call it asymmetric da okay going
back to the please more an interview
where you know when his Morgan was just
trying to always cut cut off Muhammed
hijab and speak over him or talk at the
same time over him with he's making a
good point but for those moments that
there was he wasn't yapping um M ja got
some really nice onliners out right and
those one ners just destroyed P Morgan
and just made the point that's why I
call asymmetric da when you have the
Huck on your side you might have a you
might have smaller resources or going
for the knee as you said right it's that
you might not be able to take the whole
person down but you just go for that one
point so asymmetric you go up against a
giant but you hit the right place so
it's asymmetric and maybe I would
suggest basically you know those two
giants right here Mah give us Giant in
height and abilities media training I
think we can we should create a course
for that magic well we've got the
obviously the sapiens Institute of
course we've got various things that you
know are free for the people to we've
got a learning platform and um so anyone
who wants can go sa institute.org and
and and check that out we've got st's
Institute YouTube channel where we have
all these ideologies delineated and so
I'm sure I3 have done this very similar
thing right yeah we have them we don't
have them basically still yet published
and so forth but we have a bits in
pieces but M you guys are the experts
really we would love to learn from both
of you guys maybe I'll take this
opportunity since we're almost done
basically to thank those two gentlemen
mallah and all the other speakers for
coming really here and honoring us with
their presence really in the arc three
conference for coming out here you did
the amazing job really doing the
interviews during the conference before
the conference after the conference
attending the events bless you guys
bless you anybody that made it this far
comment down below hash courage and
smash that like button inshallah we will
definitely do one-on ones with you guys
soon inshallah whenever we have time may
Allah allow us to reunite in this life
multiple times if not in jna and thank
you to the wonderful people behind the
scenes behind the cameras that y'all
can't see right now yes but we don't
want the work to go undone and unsaid
but with this being said bro exactly for
watching thank you so much for joining
us love you guys IM for the sake of
Allah may Allah Empower you guys to keep
doing what you're doing and bless you
all immensely and with that being
said we'll see you on the next
one